Okay, let's walk through this concept map. And this
lesson was all about complex traits, and most traits
are complex, and we learned about traits really for
the first time in lesson one. And there are
two main types of complex traits. We have polygenic,
and multifactorial. Both are controlled by multiple genes, but
only polygenic traits don't really have an influence from
the environment, whereas multifactorial traits do. Now, among multifactorial
traits that have a genetic and environmental component,
the variabilities seen among that trait can be explained
using something called heritability. Heritability is on a scale
from zero to one. And if there's a low
heritability, under 0.5, then it means that variability is
more influenced by the environment, whereas the higher heritability
means that the variation in the trait can be
explained by more of a genetic component, or by
certain alleles. Now, one way to estimate heritability is to use studies of
twins, both monozygotic and dizygotic. Now we
can use correlation in these studies. To
measure quantitative traits which vary continuously over
a range. Whereas, we would use concordance
to measure qualitative traits which vary discontinuously.
Which means, unlike height, which can vary
over a range of numbers from five feet,
to six feet, to seven feet. There are only
certain options, like blue eye color or brown
eye color or green eye color. So, in general,
these multifactorial traits that show a range of variability, like our risk
for breast cancer, can be measured on a spectrum. And overall this is due
to incomplete penetrance of particular alleles. So this
throws a monkey wrench into the. Simple
dominant and recessive traits we learned about in
lesson eight. And then in our search for
understanding the variability among multifactorial traits we can
use GWAS studies or Genome Wide Association
Studies. To help discover correlative alleles that might
influence these multifactorial traits. And we learned all
about alleles in lessons three, four and six.
Hopefully you enjoyed piecing all this information together if
you had some trouble why don't you go check
out the forums and see if you had any
of the same questions as some of your classmates do.